[Música]
y el 16 de octubre de 2022 fue asesinado
el periodista colombiano Rafael Moreno
en el norte de Colombia casos de
corrupción local actividades de grupos
armados ilegales malversación de fondos
eran algunos de los temas que
investigaba forbidden Stories junto a
france24 y más de 30 medios
internacionales dio seguimiento a sus
investigaciones el invitado de hoy es
Augusto Rodríguez Ballesteros director
de la unidad nacional de protección
entidad Estatal colombiana que le
prestaba seguridad al periodista una
entrevista realizada previamente por
Pascal mariani Y Felipe Morales Augusto
Rodríguez usted es el director de la
unidad nacional de protección la entidad
Estatal encargada de proteger a las
personas amenazadas de muerte en
Colombia esta entrevista la hacemos en
el marco de la investigación por la
muerte del periodista Rafael Moreno una
investigación Que reúne varios medios
nacionales e internacionales coordinada
por el consorcio forbidden Stories
Gracias por recibirnos Usted es una de
las personas más cercanas al presidente
Gustavo Petro porque lo puso al frente
de esta entidad el presidente Pedro
consciente de la situación que vive el
país y habiendo registrado nuestro
programa de gobierno durante su campaña
La promesa de traer la paz total a los
colombianos
[Música]
creyó que se necesitaba un instrumento
que había que poner a Tono modernizar
modernizarlo y
dotarlo de las herramientas necesarias
para poder proteger a los colombianos
que hoy están
Tienen algún tipo de riesgo más los que
puedan llegar por otros procesos como
nuevas poblaciones que llegan a la paz y
dejan las armas
había un desafío grande y creo que
pronto Esa fue su intención hace poco
usted fue objeto de un intento de
asesinato cuatro sicarios pues
atacaron a su esquema de seguridad y la
pregunta es porque lo quieren matar
Bueno en realidad fueron seis yo
inicialmente había visto cuatro pero
luego vi las imágenes y me di cuenta que
eran seis
Pues yo no puedo decir exactamente la
razón por la cual se llevó adelante ese
atentado criminal
lo que sí tengo es algunas razones que
me permiten aportar elementos que deben
ser considerados en las investigaciones
por las autoridades competentes y tiene
que ver con una serie de denuncias que
he venido realizando por
situaciones de corrupción situaciones
irregulares y de personas que han
formado carteles por lo menos dos
carteles
delincuenciales alrededor de la
protección que lejos de ser
hoy en día en Colombia una herramienta
para preservar la vida también la han
utilizado como un medio para
enriquecimiento de personas Ese es el
motivo yo hice algunas
denuncias sobre prácticas ilegales
corruptas
algo de narcotráfico
falsos blindajes de los vehículos
alquiler de esquemas de seguridad y de
vehículos blindados a personas que no
hacen parte de la población que se debe
proteger
terratenientes de ganaderos comerciantes
algunos artistas que vienen del exterior
incluso
para llevar vehículos que están Han sido
usados para llevar armas
alcaloides drogas
municiones y dinero en efectivo para
comprar votos en los periodos
electorales
para pasar al tema de Rafael Moreno el
16 de octubre de octubre el periodista
Rafael Moreno fue asesinado en
montelíbano sur de Córdoba según
nuestras informaciones se encontraba con
un esquema de protección de un solo
escolta y un chaleco antibalas
Rafael Moreno desistió de su servicio
del servicio del día antes de su
asesinato y según varios testigos ser
considerada que este esquema no era
suficiente para garantizar su protección
porque tenía Moreno un esquema de
protección mínimo a pesar de su
situación de alto riesgo
bueno y Rafael Moreno es una persona que
venía siendo protegida
desde hace años por la unidad nacional
de protección creo que fue desde el año
en el momento en que nosotros llegamos
encontramos unas medidas que eran
blandas por lo que se puede denominar
blandas es cuando no se incluye
un vehículo de protección en lo posible
blindado no lo tenía es probable que la
valoración del riesgo haya estado un
poco baja y de pronto haya tenido un
esquema un poco más robusto sin embargo
habría que digamos evaluarlo de una
manera mucho más exhaustiva de todas
maneras
mirando digamos el promedio de la de las
medidas que se toman
las medidas que están que se habían
tomado para él no eran demasiado bajas
tenía un hombre de protección armado que
había podido defenderlo en ese momento
pero no estaba con él porque lo había
mandado a descansar Rafael Moreno
acusaba la unidad nacional de protección
de reaccionar con la inquietud a pesar
de su nivel de riesgo que opina de esas
acusaciones
tengo que decir que
eso fue eso hace parte de una valoración
que se dio Al comenzar este gobierno
Cuando llegamos lo primero que nos dimos
cuenta es que
la entidad
reacciona demasiado lento en la el tema
que tiene que ver con la valoración del
riesgo
se está demorando aproximadamente tres
meses
valorando el riesgo e implementando un
mes o más implementando las medidas de
protección lo cual hace así que la
persona esté en un riesgo
inexplicable durante cuatro meses
eso es uno de los elementos que se puso
como tarea inmediata entrar a disminuir
drásticamente esos tiempos y de un punto
de vista histórico como explica esto de
estos problemas nos hablaba de la
caracterización esos problemas que tiene
la unidad nacional de protección bueno
en la unidad nacional de protección
proviene una entidad que fue liquidada y
cerrada es el das departamento
administrativo de seguridad
en las en los últimos años de su vida
había equivocado el camino institucional
si había dedicado a hacer espionaje a
magistrados de las altas cortes a
periodistas a políticos a parlamentarios
defendiendo Un gobierno específico
al gobierno de ese entonces es la gran
mayoría de esos funcionarios de los
funcionarios de que quedaron son los
buenos pero
existen algunos Sí y hay en este momento
personas que se ha detectado que por lo
menos hay
denuncias de prácticas incorrectas de
prácticas delincuenciales al interior de
la unidad
de protección ya que habla de estas
decisiones que ha tomado tanto
integrar la planta de los trabajadores
Como abrir las puertas de la entidad de
los entes de control que otras medidas
puede tomar para corregir estas fallas
de la unepa a nivel nacional
lo que estamos hablando de la demora en
tomar decisiones que permiten que las
personas sean asesinadas es absurdo
entonces hay que modernizarla hay que
poner por ejemplo en lo que tiene que
ver con el la con el análisis del riesgo
poner a todas las diferentes
compartimentos que investigan y que
hacen ese análisis en forma lineal
frente a la persona que hace la
solicitud no en cascada que lo atiende
una persona luego la lleva a otra y este
pedido una información hasta llega
lentamente y siga usando y la persona
Mientras tanto está en riesgo
desde el momento en que llegue la
persona a la entidad y pídala y solicite
el protección toda la entidad tiene que
saber quedar enterada que hay alguien y
todo todo mundo debe empezar a tener
todas las diferentes áreas a trabajar en
Pos de de la persona
que hay que darle la la protección la
paz total de una manera ideal debe
acercarnos a la inexistencia de riesgo
por atentado criminal contra las
personas
aspiramos y soñamos con que nos
acerquemos lo más lo máximo posible a
ese estado ideal
indudablemente que pues que no hay
perfección en los procesos y lo que sí
creemos Es que de manera paralela eso y
como resultado de una paz total ideal la
unidad nacional de protección algún día
sea mucho más pequeña de la que hoy
tenemos
la ampliación de esta entrevista y otros
detalles de este especial periodístico
internacional en la emisión de
reporteros de France 24 este domingo 23
de abril a las 8:40 de la noche hora de
Bogotá quito y Lima de momento les
invito a que sigan con nosotros en
directo a América porque volvemos en
unos segundos
[Música]